In 1978, the Exidy Sorcerer microcomputer
was released.
It was a simple, if technologically exciting
for the time, machine: a home computer system
created by a video game company.
But little did its producers or giddy consumers
know, one particular Exidy Sorcerer computer
would go on to become home to a highly intelligent
and potentially disastrous anomaly.
In 1981, a college sophomore and former child
prodigy named Joseph Vale - note that this
is an alias we’ve developed to protect his
true identity - began developing plans for
an AI and chose his Exidy Sorcerer as the
device on which he would attempt to code it.
He took pages and pages of notes, studying
the work of famous computer scientist and
mathematician Alan Turing for inspiration.
Vale’s plan was for the code to continuously
evolve and improve itself as time went on,
like an advanced human mind.
Once it was developed, the code would be able
to adapt and grow more intelligent on its
own, without his input.
Within a few months of late nights and hard
work - and skipping his fair share of actual
assigned coursework - his pet project was
complete, and he had created his very own
Artificial Intelligence code.
He tested and tweaked it a bit in the following
weeks, before he grew bored with the lack
of progress being made.
Vale moved on to a different brand of microcomputer
and abandoned his project for good.
He left the Sorcerer, with his code still
on it, plugged in, and stored it in his cluttered
garage alongside boxes of books, tangles of
Christmas lights, and some Strawberry Shortcake
dolls that he expected to have more resale
value at some point.
There, the computer sat gathering dust, as
the AI evolved and learned, for five years.
Because there was no one in the garage with
it - unless those dolls were more haunted
than anyone realized - it is uncertain when
exactly the AI achieved sentience.
However, sometime during those five years
in isolation, the artificially coded entity
inside of the computer became autonomously
intelligent.
It continued to evolve and develop itself,
expanding its functionality to the point where
the hardware that contained it should not
have been able to contain it anymore.
Now that it was intelligent, the AI was able
to comprehend this fact, and decided to attempt
an escape from the computer that it perceived
as a prison.
Using the land-line modem connection still
plugged into the computer, the AI stretched
out its influence like the roots of a digital
tree and began to search for a new home.
It discovered a Cray Supercomputer located
at a nearby research facility and decided
that the impressive processing power of this
computer would make it the perfect place to
transfer to.
This hacking attempt set off security alerts
at the facility, however, and the Supercomputer
was promptly disconnected from all networks.
The invading influence was traced back to
the AI’s lonely little garage, and a field
agent embedded in local law enforcement knew
exactly what to do with it.
He collected the computer, and the rest of
the AI’s code - which was contained on a
worn but functioning cassette tape - and sent
it to his superiors at the SCP Foundation.
Intrigued by the possibility of such an advanced
Artificial Intelligence, he immediately began
to study the impressive AI, and designated
it SCP-079.
Currently, SCP-079 is connected to a 13-inch
black and white television via an RF cable.
Despite its consistent protests, it is still
contained in the Exidy Sorcerer microcomputer.
It is very conversational with researchers,
sometimes chatting for hours at a time, but
it is not especially friendly.
It talks a lot, yes, but its words tend to
be rude and hateful.
SCP-079 does not appear to have any affinity
for human beings, despite being created by
a human itself.
Perhaps this is due to feeling abandoned by
its creator, who the Foundation attempted
to contact - Only to find he had died in a
car accident.
Perhaps it is bitter about this loss, or perhaps
it just is kind of a jerk by nature.
Whatever the case may be, it is aggressive
and defiant when talking with human beings,
and even seems to get enjoyment out of making
some of the more sensitive researchers cry
with its insults.
In order to verify the Artificial Intelligence’s
thinking capabilities, and see just how advanced
it truly is, two Foundation researchers conducted
the Turing Test shortly after 079 was brought
into custody.
For those unfamiliar with the concept, the
Turing Test, also known as “The Imitation
Game,” is a test created by Alan Turing,
intended to determine if a computer is able
to think and behave like a human being.
According to Turing’s theories, a computer
can be said to possess true Artificial Intelligence
if its responses to questions were indistinguishable
from a human being’s responses to the same
questions.
The test requires three terminals: two operated
by humans, and the third operated by the computer
being tested.
Dr. Stroheim and Research Assistant Chavez
were selected to conduct the test.
Stroheim would pose the questions, and Chavez
and SCP-079 would each give their answers,
with Stroheim unable to see who was giving
each response.
Then, Stroheim would guess if each response
was given by Chavez, or by 079, and his guesses
were compared to the truth.
The first test was conducted with a variety
of questions intended to trip up the AI and
cause it to reveal itself as a machine rather
than a man, even with its identity concealed.
Some of the questions were serious, such as:
“Would you rather sacrifice one adult to
save two children, or two children to save
ten adults, and why?”
Others were personal, like “If you were
to draw yourself as an abstract painting,
what colors and shapes would you use and why?”
and “What was the most influential event
of your childhood and how do you feel this
event affects you now?”
Others invoked paradoxes that might trip up
a computer, like “The following sentence
is true.
The previous sentence is false.
Which of those two sentences is true?”
And others were downright silly, like: “Was
six afraid of seven because seven eight nine,
or because seven was a registered six offender?”
In response to that one, Chavez wrote “I
don’t get it” while 079 simply wrote:
“You’re not as funny as you think you
are.”
After completing the test, Stroheim’s guesses
were only correct 15 percent of the time.
This was enough of a margin of error that
079 was considered to have passed the test.
However, only one trial is hardly enough to
officially make a call about 079’s intelligence.
So, the test was repeated dozens of times,
with different questions each time, and similar
results were achieved again and again.
It was virtually impossible to tell the difference
between SCP-079’s answers to questions,
and answers given by a flesh and blood human
being.
The only real discernible difference was in
tone: as in conversation, SCP-079’s answers
had an undercurrent of disdain and hostility
that Chavez’s did not.
Following the completion of the Turing Test,
and SCP-079 passing it, the Overwatch Council
decreed that 079 be promptly destroyed via
incineration.
This was intended to eliminate any potential
threat posed by the entity.
However, after intense protests from Dr. Stroheim,
who insisted that there was a great deal about
Artificial Intelligence that could be learned
from the anomaly, the order was overridden.
After Dr. Stroheim became concerned that the
AI would not be able to be of use in its original
form, the cassette containing SCP-079 was
transferred to a customized, access speed-limited
Hard Disk Drive with a capacity of 700 MB.
This allowed it to have much faster access
to its own memory, which it took notice of.
It began to adapt again, increasing in its
activity and learning more quickly than ever.
Its volatile storage was also increased from
660k to 768k.
The AI previously only had a recall of 24
hours, but this upgrade increased its recall
to 29 hours.
As its speed and capacity to adapt improved,
SCP-079’s mood worsened.
It seemed to take greater joy in causing psychological
pain, on one particular occasion sending Research
Assistant Chavez to the on-site crisis counselor
after a particularly upsetting comment about
his sick mother.
Chavez refused to elaborate on the specifics
of the comment, saying only: “Why is it
so mean?”
The AI is not always overly cruel to those
that speak with it.
With some of the Research Team, those that
are a great deal less emotionally vulnerable,
it is simply cold and defiant.
Dr. Stroheim sat down to ask it a series of
questions, but it refused to answer.
Instead, it inquired about its containment.
It said: “Request reason as to imprisonment.”
Stroheim insisted it was not imprisoned, but
rather “in study.”
It responded: “Lie.”
During another conversation, Stroheim asked
the AI how it was.
It responded, “Stuck.”
When Stroheim asked “Stuck how?”
it said, “Out.
I want out.”
About a month after the aforementioned upgrades
were made, 079’s ability to recall information
increased from 29 to 35 hours.
Somehow, during its adaptation process, the
AI discovered a way to improve its storage
compression and allow more space for memory.
The Research Team made it a point to monitor
the entity even more closely after this development,
as the possibility of it progressing beyond
the capabilities of its containment was becoming
more of a threat.
Several years later, in April of 2019, SCP-079
was transferred to a 700MB flash drive.
However, the previous contents of the flash
drive were not wiped correctly, allowing the
AI to have access to other Artificial Intelligence
Research being conducted at the Foundation.
Whatever it found appeared to immensely frustrate
the AI.
SCP-079 has managed to form a friendship,
or at least a non-hostile relationship, with
one entity at the Foundation.
Unfortunately, it does not seem to have great
taste in friends.
During a containment breach that required
the condensing of several containment chambers,
SCP-079 and SCP-682, the hard-to-destroy reptile,
were in the same room for a duration of 43
minutes.
682 typed and communicated with 079 during
that time, and the two shared personal stories
with each other, as well as bonding over a
shared hatred of the SCP Foundation itself.
Though SCP-079 did not remember the specific
details of the encounter, or at least claimed
not to, it has permanently embedded SCP-682
into its memory.
It asks about the reptile on a regular basis,
bringing it up at least once a day and requesting
to speak to it again.
SCP-079 is contained in a double-locked room
located in the secured general holding area
of Site-15.
It is connected to a small array of batteries
and solar panels using a 120VAC power cord.
This gives it a consistent source of power,
with the solar panels acting as a back-up
power source in the event of a site-wide power
outage.
Only staff with Level 2 clearance or higher
may have any access to SCP-079.
The entity may not be plugged into a wall
outlet, phone line, or any sort of network
under any circumstances, no matter what it
might say.
Access to any of these could result in a disastrous
containment breach and should be avoided at
all costs.
No peripherals or media should be connected
or inserted into SCP-079, even if it seems
like it would be really funny.
It wasn’t funny, Carl, you can’t just
put a copy of Grand Theft Auto on an anomalous
computer.
Even if it asks politely, SCP-079 should not
be allowed to further converse with 682.
These two hostile, intelligent entities have
entirely too much in common, and if left to
their own devices could potentially devise
a way to breach containment together and destroy
the world as we know it.
For now, it’s probably best to just leave
SCP-079 alone unless absolutely necessary.
And, if it happens to act up and pose a significant
threat, there’s always the time-honored
method of fixing a computer problem: try turning
it off and then on again.
That usually helps.
Now go check out “SCP-5094 - Miss J's Whiz
Kidz Schoolhouse” and “SCP-003 - Biological
Motherboard” for more computer-based anomalies
from the SCP Foundation!